cet homme est l'un des trente et un
suspect arrêté en lien avec une enquête
de traite de personnes en ontario
les victimes toutes des femmes dans la
vingtaine et la trentaine aurait été
exploités sexuellement
chaque jour ces victimes ont subi des
agressions sexuelles et toutes sortes
d'autres gestes dégradants
alors qu'elle était sous le joug de ces
criminels violents explique le chef
adjoint de la police régionale de york
la police a identifié 12 victimes et la
majorité d'entre elles sont québécoises
avec une fois qu'elles ont été recrutés
au québec
elles sont continuellement se déplacer
plus à l'ouest du pays explique taille
trong de la police régionale des yeux et
se retrouve seul complètement démunis
dans un arbre qui ne connaissent pas et
auquel ils peuvent pas s'adresser aux
jeunes facilement pour obtenir de l'aide
l'enquêté a débuté en octobre 2018
lorsque deux victimes québécoises ont
contacté la police est jeune femme
tentait de fuir l'homme soupçonné d'être
à la tête du réseau
j'en atteignent anguilla le travail de
corps policiers ontariens et de l'équipe
intégrée de lutte contre le proxénétisme
du québec ont permis de démanteler le
réseau
je suis tombé mort donnée ces
arrestations rappelle de mauvais
souvenirs à marjolaine où les dont la
fille a été victimes d'exploitation
sexuelle
elle souhaiterait plus des aides pour
les jeunes femmes il ya vraiment un gros
processus de lavage de cerveau qui est
fait chez nos jeunes femmes et sont à ce
jour je connais rien qu'ils aient des
programmes pour rien qu'ils aient des
programmes de ça il y a tout de même eu
du progrès selon ce chercheur de
l'institut universitaire jeunes en
difficulté milieu faisait les
initiatives mais rares étaient ceux qui
étaient capables de se parler et d'avoir
une bonne intervention coordonnée on
essaie de trouver une seule et même
réponse cohérente pour justement après
cette la mer réponse possible à ces
jeunes là le réseau aurait fait au moins
33 autres victimes
les suspects font face à plus de 300
accusations dont traite de personnes et
participation aux activités d'une
organisation criminelle
ici valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal